on Saturday there was yet another terror
attack on American soil a non-violent
protest or was killed by a white
supremacist ignoring it is just as bad
as supporting it Seth Meyers Jimmy
Kimmel and Jimmy Fallon addressed the
violence at a white nationalist rally in
Charlottesville Virginia during their
respective late-night shows Monday night
Fallon was visibly upset
what happened over the weekend in
Charlottesville Virginia was just
disgusting my daughters are in the next
room playing and I'm thinking how can I
explain to them that there's so much
hatred in this world The Tonight Show
host said he used his platform to speak
out largely because he feels a
responsibility to lead by example for
his daughters four-year-old Winnie and
two-year-old Francis I can't look at my
beautiful growing curious daughters and
say nothing when this kind of thing is
happening we all need to stand against
what is wrong acknowledge that racism
exists and stand up for what is right
Meyers addressed his audience from his
desk he passionately condemned President
Donald Trump's remarks following the
rally his job is to lead and to
absolutely and unequivocally and
immediately condemn what is evil in US
and if he does not do that if he's not
preside over our society then he's not a
president as for Kimmel his tone was
much less somber but equally fiery as he
too criticized Trump the president this
morning decided to take the difficult
step of condemning Nazis in the Klan
which was big for him because this is
the sort of thing that could alienate
his base